What is the best way to ensure you get enough protein?
Well
Maybe a better question is what are the best? What are foods that contain the most protein?
Because you only get enough protein by consuming it.
So you have to consume foods that have protein in the best way to get protein is through eating animal product, animal needs.
So
it's really
very difficult to get enough protein, be it out of vegan diet.
And certainly for a cancer patient who needs even more protein, because remember you need about a gram of protein
per pound of body weight. So if you weigh 150 pounds, you really need it's best to consume about 150 grams of protein a day.
Well, that's difficulty, but if you're not a vegan, it's very difficult if you're a vegan to consume 150 grams of protein a day.
In a non meat source.
So that's a challenge for everybody. So that's typically when I recommend for somebody who has a diagnosis of cancer, if you don't have a diagnosed cancer, you could probably do it with less than that. But
remember cancer patients need protein consumption in order to make
the subset of lymphocytes, natural killer cells and T cells that are responsible for killing cancer cells. So
you need to get that protein. So it's hard to get that
with just a vegan diet you have to eat meat. Now this person asked a second question. Can I had protein powder to my daily drink? If so, which one is best? Yes, you can. So the best one I think we've
sculpted the market on this is also the cleanest one. And it has the lowest amount of glutamated, which is the US enzymes brand.
Same price as the other ones at the market. So it's not any more expensive, but it's it's it's the cleanest one out there. It doesn't have
it's tested for chemicals and and no more source material. As well as it has the lowest amount of glutamate. They make it in a chocolate variety and a vanilla variety and everybody that takes it has said at the moment. So I think that's the best one to do.
Now you got to remember you're only going to get about 20, 25 grams of protein scoop, couple scoops of protein powder. So it's still not, you know, if you're drinking a daily drink, anyhow, you might so throw some of that in there. So you're getting to protein. But that's not going to be a substitute for you eating eating animal meat. So just remember that. So US enzymes we have on our story.